information that so long as it wasn't
classified that the American public
should know what is your life be like
since you left the agency what's a lot
different I can now tell people where I
work I'm no longer leading a double life
and since I left the agency I've gotten
married and had a baby and I've realized
that being a mother is about ten times
harder than being a spy and nobody gives
you training for that thank you very
much on November 1st 1950 an
assassination plot against President
Truman resulted in a 38 second gunfight
near the White House Pulitzer Prize
winning film critic Stephen hunter and
journalist John Bainbridge jr. tell the
story in their new book American
gunfight next learn the details then
accompany the authors to the scene of
the crime
outside Blair House
good evening everyone and officially now
welcome I'm bill Starr the executive
director of the Georgia Center for the
book at the DeKalb County Public Library
we're delighted to have you with us
tonight and we're delighted to have an
audience from c-span joining us for this
wonderful program with Stephen hunter a
very quick announcement for you first
about another program coming up this
week
Al Franken will be co-sponsored by the
Georgia Center for the book at the Jimmy
Carter library tomorrow night we'd be
happy to have you there and on Thursday
night in this same auditorium we will
have the novelist Petey determine who
will be here discussing his brand-new
novel called the cat dancers it's a
thriller about revenge and murder which
is set in the mountains of North
Carolina our guest tonight is a Pulitzer
Prize winning author he has won Pulitzer
for film criticism in 2003 for his work
for the Washington Post newspaper
Stephen hunter is also the best-selling
author of a dozen action adventure
novels and two collections of film
criticism in his novels he has created
two very remarkable distinctive and
memorable characters at least - one of
them as fans will well know is known as
Bob the nailer and by vet Bob the nailer
is a master sniper and by Naylor he gets
his man the other character is and he's
the the hero of the most recent novel I
believe called Havana a Earl savage
novel and Earl savage is an ex-marine he
is a state policeman and he is a deadly
guy now these novels that Stephen hunter
has written have generated enormous
enormous ly good reviews and they have
generated thousands of new readers for
the authors books Publishers Weekly said
of his books no one writes
better gun fight scenes and that indeed
was good preparation for the book that
he has written a non-fiction book that
he's here to discuss tonight which is
American gunfight the plot to kill Harry
Truman and the shootout that stopped it
in this concern an assassination attempt
against the then President of the United
States in 1950 it is an assassination
attempt that for reasons mr. hunter will
explain has been quite neglected by
historians no longer American gunfight
rectifies that and in brilliant fashion
the book has been written by Stephen
hunter co-authored with John Bainbridge
of the Baltimore Sun we're delighted to
have with us tonight the author of this
book mr. Stephen hunter please join me
and welcome him to the Georgia Center
for the book
thank you all very much thank you for
squeezing into the middle I I feel
important all of a sudden I'm going to
begin with less his name is les Coffelt
he's 38 years old
he's an Army veteran he spent five years
as a metropolitan policeman Washington
DC before the war and he spent five
years after the war as a White House
policeman les is sitting in the dog
house the dog house is a guard house in
front of Blair House which is the
temporary residence of harry s truman
the president United States the date is
November 1st 1950 the time is 2:20 p.m.
the temperature is about 85 degrees it's
hotter than hell les is probably grumpy
but you could never guess that from
looking at less because less is that
convivial figure of mythology the
laughing policeman the smiling policeman
but he's it for real he's never used the
authority of the badge of the size of
the gun or the bigness of the cap or the
or the BRIT breadth of his tunic to
intimidate people he has an open face he
has an open manner
everybody loves les les is a very very
decent man I just an extraordinary man
is married he has a stepdaughter he's
probably the only good swell now I can't
say that he is a rare there's always
evil stepparents in popular culture not
knowing any stepparents I can't say
that's good or bad he was a good
stepparent and his daughter Janie to
this day loves and Revere's his memory
he's a wonderful stepparent he's also in
hundreds of photographs because of all
the men who stood guard around the
president he was the one the tourist
approached they'd always asked if they
could take his picture in front of Blair
House or in front of the White House all
the other cops were sort of burly and
intimidating and bristly and the
tourists were afraid but lesson always
say yes so you see dozens of pictures of
les with his
around Dennis from Ohio and you know
Cowboys from Nevada and you know
Americans who've come to see the house
where the president lives les is sitting
in his booth November 1st 80 degrees
220 p.m. suddenly there's a shadow in
front of him shadow is the shadow of a
young man named grisolia torresola he's
five six he weighs about a hundred and
ten pounds wearing a brown suit with
pinstripes wearing a brown fedora it's
extremely well-dressed he looks like a
lawyer or a banker the width of a
mustache
someone had saw him the other day the
day before thought he looked like a
divinity student because he has a very
sort of solemn religious kind of intense
serious demeanour not very demonstrative
at all one thing about him is
demonstrative and that's the German
Luger he's got in his hands he's holding
the gun close to his chest he's holding
it about six inches from less he pulls
the trigger four times first bullet hits
less here the second bullet hits less
here the third bullet hits less in the
hip and the fourth bullet just misses
goes actually through the tunic and out
the back of the of the of the guardhouse
less does what any man shot three times
with nine-millimeter steel case
ammunition will do he sat back and he
commenced a bleed and slide off into
coma Vassiliou meanwhile steps around
the guardhouse the first thing he sees
in another man entering Blair house
about 20 feet away he raises his pistol
he fires three times he brings that man
down that man is another policeman he's
actually been on a very weird mission
but it was normalcy for the Secret
Service in 1950 they didn't care about
gunmen they didn't care about assassins
they were terrified of poisoners someone
had read too many Agatha Christie novels
so every morning they sent this guy out
to buy groceries at a random grocery
store to defeat the poison threat and he
did defeat the poison threat
he caught three bullets in the neck and
back he staggered in the house
he pulled the door shut behind him and
screamed I'm hit im hit
Basilio then turned to the right and
what he saw it to the right was a police
officer named Donald Byrd Zell who was
bleeding from one knee Donald Byrd Zell
had been standing in front of Blair
House Donald Byrd Zell had been shot by
gracilis friend and co-conspirator oscar
collazo and now Donald was returning the
favor he was shooting at gros Sileo so
were two other Secret Service men and
another white house policeman this was
at the far end of the property about a
hundred feet away you know one of the
things we learned in researching this
book was how many shots are fired in
gunfights and how few of them hit the
target and how full of anomalies they
are how full of strange things they are
we're Sileo of being shot at from all
sides you know what he does he sits down
the reason he sits down is he's shot so
many times he's now out of ammunition
and he's not too good with the gun he's
carrying and he can't figure out what to
do so you've got one gunman sitting down
trying to figure out his gun while
bullets are zinging and popping all
around him you've got cops surrounding
him firing at him
you've got grass Illya a few feet away
very calmly surveying the situation
gracilis again holding the Luger with
two hands and fires
he hits Donald Byrd Zell and the other
knee Donald Byrd Zell went through three
years of combat and the Pacific and
wasn't scratched and now inside of ten
seconds he's been shot once in each knee
he falls to the ground he collapses this
is the moment that we all ought to think
about this is the moment really when
there's a lot at stake maybe even the
life of the President of the United
States is at stake why you asked because
these two men never got inside Blair
House they didn't have to get inside
Blair House
here's what happened Harry Truman was
upstairs in his underwear taking a nap
he'd had a very hard morning he'd
months of appointments he had a bunch of
policy meetings he'd handed out the
Congressional Medal of Honor to a very
brave marine veteran of the Battle of
Iwo Jima guy named justice Chamberlain
and he'd had a couple of more meetings
now he was taking a nap so he sound
asleep and something wakes him
it's gunfire maybe he recognized it
maybe he didn't but if you recall he's
from the show-me-state
way Bainbridge and I my co-author
Bainbridge we laughed a lot about what
various other American presidents would
have done if they'd heard gunshots
outside on the street I believe you to
assign your most hated president is
acting the most poorly anyway
what Harry Truman died did was very
brave and very stupid he got up out of
bed he walked to the window he opened it
and he looked out so there you have it
and this incidentally Margaret
acknowledges us in her book evidently
best gave Harry hell for doing this
several other State Department people
our executive people said to him you
know that wasn't very wise mr. president
Jim Raleigh who was on The Secret
Service said Joan you know mr. president
do you remember the war first I remember
the war he had been in our Tillery
officer and he said yeah and Jim Riley
said when a shell got off what did you
what did you do and Harry said well I
ducked I got down in my and then he
looked at and he said I see what you're
saying Jim and you're right anyway Harry
goes to the window let's freeze frame
right there Harry Truman is at the
window he's looking out the window 31
feet away and we know because we
measured it with a laser rangefinder is
gracilis or Isola guerrilla gross Illya
who shot three men Cresselia is young
determined very angry very passionate he
has given his life up to this cause only
thing has to do is insert a new magazine
in his Luger and turn we're not saying
he saw the president but he could have
seen the present and here's you know who
had seemed Brazil
only four men and three of them had been
shot the fourth was across the street in
the executive office building watching
all this he obviously was of no use the
other Secret Service men were still
obsessed with and concerned with and
wrapped up in the drama of oscar collazo
other Secret Service and White House
police personnel were in the house they
weren't sure what was going on they
weren't sure what to do these things
happen fast when it happens it happens
fast that's what people say 38 seconds
this is about second 20 I would guess
maybe 25 5 seconds maybe 10 seconds when
grrah sylia is standing all by himself
30 feet from the president united states
we interrupt the story to bring you a
message from the author let me tell you
how I wrote this book how I came across
this episode people say to me Steve how
did you find it and I wish I could say
I'm just a damn genius but the truth
that I did something much easier I
remembered it not because I was there
and not because I could read when I was
4 years old in 1950 but because in 1957
back when I wanted to be an FBI agent or
a private investigator or a sheriff or a
marshal or something like that before I
before I knew I'd end up being a movie
critic anyway I
I read the landmark book of The Secret
Service and I never forgot the story of
Les Coffelt
and it sunk into my head it went way
down far away it just disappeared and
it's not as if in the intervening years
it ever came up it may have once or
twice I don't remember but literally 40
years later I'm a professional writer
I'm living in Baltimore Maryland I'm
working for The Washington Post
I'm engaged to a beautiful woman I have
two beautiful children I have a
reasonably happy first wife things are
going well except for one problem I
don't have a book to write so I'm trying
to think of books to write and I wanted
to write a book about a gunfight in the
book I just
and I thought what I would do is take a
real gunfight and try and choreograph
this sort of madness the craziness the
anomalies the ducking the luck the
absurdities of it and these are very
intense experiences that literally make
no sense when analyzed where Ashley
because everyone is operating with a
drugstore full of chemicals natural
chemicals in their blood they're also
not breathing and their fingers have
swollen and their IQs have dropped 30
points so they're acting very peculiarly
and I didn't think any movie I'd seen a
thousand gunfights in the movies I don't
think any movie ever caught it off never
got it right I've written a bunch of gun
fights in books I didn't think I'd ever
gotten it right so I decided I would
take an actual gun fight
and figure out exactly what happened I'd
used the actual events as a template and
I write a novel I'd take my skills as a
novelist and I'd apply them against this
narrative situation I'd make up
characters I'd make up motives I'd make
up milieu I make up locations I do
everything a novelist does it's several
other candidates thought about the OK
Corral problem with that as it's been
done too much thought about the gunfight
that ended the life of babyface Nelson
very dramatic he was probably the most
violent American criminal that I could
have fun with a total bull goose tommy
gun toting loony like him thought of
some others some famous some not so
famous then I thought of this and the
more I thought about it the more I liked
it so I said to myself before I make my
mind up before I commit to this I've got
to figure out whether it's worth doing
so let me read the standard volume so I
looked for the standard volume that's
why I made the shocking discovery there
was no standard volume there was a
couple of paragraphs in biographies of
Truman there was a couple of I think
there was a story in some imitation of
American heritage magazine that I found
on the internet it turned out there was
a long and extremely detailed story done
in The New Yorker in 1952 by
Robert Donovan who later did pt-109 but
there was no book-length study that told
the story of this day start to finish
told the history and the politics and
most of all the story of the people
there's only one problem with writing
that book and that was I was too lazy
and stupid to do it I couldn't do it it
wasn't within my capabilities I don't
have that kind of fact raised
professional mind you know I don't have
the ability or the empathy to go back
and interview people five or six times
certainly had no interest in entering
the politics of Puerto Rican I'm sorry
the waters of Puerto Rican politics
which made no sense to me whatsoever
didn't want to learn about politics I
didn't want to learn at the history of
Puerto Rico to me I knew the name of one
Puerto Rican and that was Natalie Wood
in West Side Story so I set a magic word
the magic word wasn't Shazam and it
wasn't abracadabra it was Bainbridge
Bainbridge my friend John Bainbridge a
former colleague from the Baltimore Sun
fabulous guy great big galumphing guy
very smart sort of at loose ends looking
for something to do wanted always to
write a book he tried a couple of books
hadn't really worked out so I asked him
John do you think you could do this for
me would you could you do could you work
for me and do all this hard work and
keep track of all this stuff and lay it
out in an outline for me to work from
and he said yes and we were off I wish I
could say it was easy it wasn't I wish I
could say it was fun wasn't fun at all
in fact I had a heart attack halfway
through it it was so unfun but somehow
we got it done somehow I was able to
bring what I my image for the book was
what you might call a nonfiction
thriller I wanted very much to structure
like a thriller I also wanted to in a
way that historians don't do intimately
evoke the lives of these men
I wanted to know their domestic
situation I want to know how
they got along with their wives I wanted
to know what their hobbies were what
kind of cars they drove whether they
smoked with their military backgrounds
where they were from I wanted to do that
across the board I knew that I didn't
want to dismiss the Puerto Ricans you
know I didn't want it to be an anti
Puerto Rican book in which I make fun of
the Puerto Ricans as far too many people
in this country have and I wanted to
understand
well actually what I wanted was I wanted
bad Brits to understand so he could
explained to me the nuances of Puerto
Rican history and Puerto Rican politics
and he as I say he did a fabulous job
and what we ended up with is a book
that's very confounding to some because
it's not really a history there'll be
better books written about Harry Truman
and it's not really a gunfight books but
there's a lot of guns stuff in it it's
not really a thriller because everything
in it is true it's not really oh you
know it's certainly not a book of policy
it doesn't illuminate it lengthy
tortured relations between Puerto Rico
and the United States it's it's a story
I to me my whole life has been about
stories and my approach to the material
was tell the story and I understood that
in order to tell the story I had to stop
the montt the momentum here and there to
give you background on Puerto Rico to
give you background on some of the
players to give you background on Harry
Truman that you had to understand who
these men were you had to understand who
les Coffelt was you had to understand
who Floyd boring was you had to
understand who oscar collazo was and we
worked very very hard to try and do this
we believe we succeeded well I hope you
buy it I hope you I hope you agree with
me that we've done it now let's go back
to November 1st 1950 if you recall when
we left him Les Paul felt was sitting on
the ground or sitting on a chair with
three bullets in him bleeding to death
other two police officers around him
were down and unconscious across the
street a man was watching out the window
of the executive office building Harry
Truman was looking out the window of his
room his bedroom Andrew Sileo torresola
was reloading what would grow sylia have
done Brasilia would have killed Truman I
don't think Oscar would have Oscar had
issues Oscar was a last-minute recruit
to this operation Oscar was in many ways
I hate to say this of a presidential
assassin but the truth is he's a very
good man he's a good father he worked
incredibly hard he'd come to this
country in the 20s he'd learned English
he'd gone to and from he's he's raised
children he'd eventually taught himself
a trade he's very active is in his
community he was as I've said elsewhere
he was an exemplary man except for the
38 seconds in which he tried to kill the
president the United States he actually
made a very good very fine prisoner
believe it or not but I don't think
Oscar would have shot to kill I do think
rasilla was I do think resilient the
most dangerous man out there vasilia was
26 he'd been brought up as the kind of
the godson or the special boy of a man
named Pedro Albizu Campos B's oucampus
was the spirit of this issue that makes
no sense to Americans
it's called Puerto Rican independence
why would they want to be independent
well because people want to be
independence to some people freedom is
worth dying for and it's worth killing
for
even freedom from a benevolent ruler
like the United States and of course one
of the ironies here is of all the
presidents of the United States of all
the presidents who were president after
1918 99 when we took over Puerto Rico
true and was far and away the most
sensitive to Puerto Rico and he wanted
the best for Puerto Rico but there is
was on the island a very strong
independence movement and there was a
splinter of that group called the
Nationalist Party and they they they had
this
session with violent separation from the
United States and in fact if you look at
the history there was a guerrilla war
between them and their own government
the colonial government and the United
States for about 40 years was led by
this fellow Pedro Albizu Campos who is
kind of the Benton war maybe even the
villain of our book brilliant guy is
born illegitimately in Ponce a before
the First World War
went to Harvard I mean stop and think
how you go from being an illegitimate
kid in the slums of a city in Puerto
Rico to Harvard and Harvard Law School
you understand that you're talking about
a brilliant driven man could have done
anything but he just angry a lot of
things made him angry we're not really
sure what made him angry is maybe there
was a racial component he was half
mestizo and he felt he felt prejudiced
against he felt he was a first
lieutenant in the Army in World War one
but evidently he'd been treated rudely
by a sergeant somewhere and that really
festered perhaps it was when he got to
Harvard he realized he wasn't as
brilliant as he thought he was and there
were a lot of other brilliant people in
the world we saw his grades he got
surprisingly mediocre grades we
speculate that maybe that was somewhat
disheartening for him and disorienting
to him then there was the issue of his
father his father was Basque his father
was a prominent store merchant in ponse
and if he never embraced Pedro but he
did sponsor him he did help him and it
was through the father's intercession
with his Lodge a Masonic Lodge that
Pedro was sent first to the University
of Vermont he'd been a brilliant school
child he was sent to the University of
Vermont when he was in Vermont he met a
professor from Harvard who'd been really
really really inspirational towards him
impressed with him and who arranged for
his Harvard politics at any rate he was
just angry and he until 1932 he was the
spirit of nationalism
and until 1932 he very much wanted to
stay
for office and he wanted to pursue his
goals legally in 1932 he lost the
election he stood for on his party lost
and this was after they thought that
they were going to do well because they
were attracting huge crowds and at that
point he began to get violent and from
that point there are assassinations
there are ambushes there is sort of a
small war of terror and counter-terror
very familiar stuff now you know we know
this story before
sounds very sounds very 21st century to
me gunfights in in slums and there was a
terrible episode in 1930 a police chief
was assassinated policemen were
assassinated very tough times Albizu
campus was eventually arrested on
weather rather unpersuasive charges they
could never really link him exactly to
what what they thought he did but he
spent 10 years in prison then he came
back to Puerto Rico and he lived in high
yuya where it was Sileo was from Basilio
was very young at that time Andrew Sileo
grew up as one of his bodyguards that's
where it was silly I learned to shoot
the guns were provided by Puerto Rican
veterans who come back from World War
two that's why they were Germans service
pistols Basilio learned to shoot then
and he became Don Pedro's special boy he
became Don Pedro's number one guy and he
was sent to America in 1948 because Don
Pedro we believe was planning a
revolution and that revolution was to
take part in three separate zones it was
to take part in Puerto Rico for five
cities would erupt in insurrection
police stations would be burned post
offices would be burned the flag of the
Free Republic was going to stand take
place in San Juan where the governor of
Puerto Rico Luis Munoz marine would be
assassinated and a commando team of 50
men was assigned to do that it would
take place in the United States or
another commando team of five men led by
grisolia would shoot their way
in the Blair House and kill Harry Truman
who shoot their way into the White House
and kill Harry Truman and you know what
if they had done that they would have
brought it off but what happened was
like many grand plans it fell apart okay
someone someone snitched them out they
were worried the police would Pedro
Albizu Campos under very under
essentially house arrest and eventually
besieged him the men began to leak away
only the hardcore were left they didn't
want to go but they felt obligated to go
so instead of tacking la Fortaleza with
50 men they attacked it with five men
they were wiped out
four days later Brasilia elinoz from the
white house are attacked Blair House the
other four men decided not to do it
Oh scar was a last-minute replacement
didn't know anything about guns at all
had never done any of this kind of work
grow Sileo just made him you know just
asked him to come along because he'd
given his heart to Don Pedro he said
goodbye to his whole life and he went
off so that's how come Brasilia is there
that's how Congress Elio is so hard hard
and that's how come I believe and my
colleague believed after looking at this
and and after you know ten Freedom of
Information Act requests to see top
secret documents from the Secret Service
after six trips to Puerto Rico after
John having hired three translators and
spent much of the last year reading
never before translated Spanish reporter
a Spanish port history text that's why
we believe that the President of the
United States was in mortal danger for
those five seconds and there was no one
there to stop them who could stop him
well less Coffelt with free bullets in
him got up fired one shot hit crew Sileo
one inch above the ear killed his ass
dead and then and then slipped back into
his chair
an hour later was declared dead on the
operating table thank you very much
I will be very happy to answer questions
yes sir the 80 degrees on November the
1st in Washington DC that must have been
a real unusual it was an unusual warmth
sir I don't know if you've ever spent
any time in Washington it has weather as
perverse as its politics and it it may
be that's why people there are so insane
because because it it it just it makes
no sense at all but that's verifiably
what happened and to make it more
grotesque Bess Truman forbade air
conditioning so everybody was really hot
and on top of that because it was after
Labor Day the men by bureaucratic Fiat
had to wear their winter tunics even
though it was 80 degrees out
they were hotter than health and the
funny thing is it stayed hot for another
four or five days unless if you look at
the funeral pictures he was buried
November 4th in Arlington National
Cemetery and you know everybody is in is
in suit coats it was it makes no sense
it shouldn't be but I was wearing a polo
shirt in Washington just a few days ago
so there you go
yes sir and the later president was
Jimmy Carter here's what happened well I
can't tell you what had happened and if
you want to know why I've been asked
that question a number of times I should
by this time have a better answer to be
honest with you I honestly don't know I
suspect that there was knowing Carter a
little not knowing him personally but
just my sense of his presidency it was a
combination of compassion and practical
politics he Ostara was found guilty of
murder he was sentenced to death he was
on death row for two years and right
before his death and right before Harry
Truman left office Harry Truman commuted
his sentence to life imprisonment
Escarra then spent 26 years total in
prison he was
he was sort of released as part of a
general initiative to win favor with
Latin voters he was part of a package I
don't think Carter ever thought hard
about him the the people that were also
released and I perhaps I should have
mentioned this but I got all head up and
I forgot where I was
four years later and even more remark
well I won't say more remarkable I will
say a more charismatic but a less
dangerous thing happened and that is
four men three men and a woman from the
Puerto Rican Nationalist Party pulled
guns in the house chambers in the
Capitol in the US Capitol and opened
fire and they wounded four congressmen
one of them seriously and those four
people were pardoned they were the main
beneficiaries of the pardon and Carter
included included him in the partner but
I you know the truth is I honestly I
can't give you you know the answer that
you want I'll be honest with you I wish
I could I probably tomorrow I'll be able
to yes certain situations whatever
believes they have why do you think this
incident didn't fall into that
conspiracy error a lot of people kind of
picked it up and start any held of their
own doesn't it's a real good question
and I think part of it is that the
universe wasn't paranoid then we didn't
see death and conspiracy lurking
everywhere and in fact although the
United States the police apparatus of
the United States believed that this was
a conspiracy and I think Bainbridge and
I have I can't say we've proven but
we've uncovered considerable
circumstantial evidence that suggests
also then it was a legitimate conspiracy
it's never proven in a court of law
and somehow their minds just didn't work
that
the universe was perceived of is
different Harry Truman himself said well
that's the sort of thing a president has
to expect now and then you know it was
it was just sort of an understanding
that stuff happened that there were
crazy people who did crazy things and it
wasn't really until the Kennedy
assassination and the explosion of books
seeing conspiracy in that that
conspiracy became a kind of an
assumption or a presumption of the
reality of the universe and it always
been a cottage industry among thriller
writers for conspiracy and there's
always been a kind of a seamy underbelly
like the protocols of the Elders of Zion
and things like that that argued all
kinds of meretricious conspiracies but
but it wasn't until the Kennedy
assassination that conspiracy became
mainstream and ceased to go away so
nowaday and here's one here's another
thing to some degree and I know this
better than anyone working in Washington
media has changed dramatically there
were only you know two national
newspapers in those days probably the
New York Times and the in the LA Times
or maybe the Chicago Tribune that
television news was in its infancy there
was no videotape so there was no there
were lots of photographs but there was
no dramatic record that could be played
over and over again there was also no
culture of commentary today if something
happens in Washington with all these you
know 24-hour news cycles that event will
be discussed endlessly and tape from it
will be shown endlessly and to a certain
degree it is it is memorialized and
permanent eyes it's it's it's inserted
into our memory in a very powerful way
and it lasts longer and the longer it's
sort of at play in the imagination the
more chance there is the more fun there
is the more profit there is and coming
up with darker conspiratorial
explanations you could we had fun I
won't bore you with them but you could
look at this event and come up with
conspiracy theories behind I mean really
you know ridiculous conspiracy theories
like the presence of the Masons is very
interesting there's a lot of a lot of
these men were Mason's les was a Mason
Albizu Campos was helped by the Masons
most of the White House security force
were were Masons I don't know much about
Mason's but I just know that that's a
breeding ground for people with
conspiratorial mindsets and someone
could have lots of fun and you know make
some enemies and make some money playing
that game we chose we chose not to play
that game
there's also the bullet that killed
Basilio was never recovered it went
through his head it's what they call a
through-and-through and it disappeared
in those days forensic pathology was not
what it is today the police
this is unbelievable the police never
cordoned off the site and with 20
minutes within 10 minutes there are 200
civilians and photographers just walking
around kicking looking at things picking
up stuff so I don't know what happened
to that bullet maybe it sunk into the
ground maybe somebody pulled it off but
the truth is we can't you know there's
no hard evidence I mean the only
evidence that that last shot Brasilia is
is because someone else did because no
one else could have nobody else was in a
place to do it and he was definitely
shot anything else yes
the the job that I was cars defense team
did well if you read the trial
transcript here's what you see you see
that they here's what you see you see
that Oscar is very smart and you see
that he basically ran his own defense
they wanted him to plead guilty by
insanity there was a very weird episode
in which people offered him money to
plead guilty by insanity he always
believed in his family always believed
that the colonial government was on that
because they wanted him to but they
wanted to trivialize this they didn't
wanted to bring up they wanted they
wanted these people to be crazy as
opposed to having legitimate grievances
against the United States but I will say
that Oscar's defense team gave Oscar a
lot of latitude and let him do what he
want even at the expense of mounting an
effective defense and what he wanted was
to use his trial as a bully pulpit and
if you read the trial transcript if you
can find it it took us six to eight
months to find it I'll sell you our copy
for $50,000 anyway actually we're
donating ours to the Truman library so
you can read it eventually but but but
they gave him a bully pulpit to avoid
that so he could make his points about
Puerto Rico and he gave alongs
impassioned speech he told the history
of Puerto Rico he recalls some events
and he never really evaded the charges
the government space was very narrow the
government found him guilty of murdering
Les Paul felt although he didn't shoot
Lesko film he was fifty feet away and
the only thing his defense attorneys did
their argument was that he didn't know
that gracilis was going to kill
he didn't really even know what was
going on he just was there to make a
demonstration and whatever that word
means the way alby's accomplice
expressed himself almost poetically and
he would tell people he would ask people
to do things and they would do them
based on their interpretation like he
told these men to go to the White House
and put on a demonstration and so they
pulled guns and in close range start
shooting police officers but you know I
always thought what they could have done
you know because I here's a funny thing
as I wrote this book is we got to know
these guys it's really easy to hate
people from afar if you see them as
demons you want them demonize it's real
easy to hate them and I think cops have
got to do that I'm glad the FBI
demonized them and arrested you know and
I'm glad the Secret Service people
demonize them but as a writer I couldn't
demonize them and I just got to know
them and they were there very
interesting men i they were so different
from that sort of motley crew of
screwballs that have tried to kill
presidents including Lee Harvey Oswald
and John Wilkes Booth they were much
different than any of those guys and
they were very very interesting so we
tried to draw their portraits with some
compassion but I think that that case I
mean you know it wasn't the most
brilliant defense but it seemed to me
like they gave a scar what Ostara wanted
you can argue possibly that their duty
was to defend him regardless of what I
was Gaara wanted but you know but that's
just that's just what they did yes ma'am
my question has nothing to do with the
shooting but you do have some little
personal stories about President Truman
abyss and
I wonder if you know anything about this
musical background was he classically
trained or did he just play the piano by
the seat of his pants it's interesting
he was actually visited that he loved
music he loved classical music and his
first visitor that day was see you'll
probably recognize this name Rudolph
Rimmel he wrote what was that the love
song of the donkey the donkey love song
the Grand Canyon sweet yeah well you all
know more about him that I do at any of
that he I'd we just did encounter that
he was very musical and he and his wife
played the piano every night and they
sang whether he was a trained pianist or
a seat-of-the-pants penis that I
honestly don't know but I do know that
music was very important to him in a way
it was also really and I was very
important to Les and his wife crusty and
they sang and played the piano I mean
the piano I guess now we just turn on
the TV or play a video game but in those
days the piano was the focus of a lot of
you know entertainment every night it
was it was the magic box I I just can
tell you that he loved music
particularly classical music and he
played it and and it was very important
to his imagination I can't answer the
question about the degree of his
training I wish I wish I knew
yes sir
in Georgia and I'm so thrilled to just
thank you very much
Ritu books also press publish and just
shout out to you in his legs will come I
want to know why a lot dogs then why
Harry Truman was backing up why I should
have said yeah the White House was a
dump by 1948 it was literally unlivable
and it had been unlivable for many many
years and Harry Truman was the only
president who had the gumption to sort
of deal with this issue and he
commissioned a two-year remodeling
project and as a consequence he and his
wife moved across the street to Blair
House which is it's about I'd say a
hundred yards kitty-corner that's
actually it's two buildings built in the
1840s that have sort of merged into one
on the interior though it looks like two
buildings from the outside it's about a
hundred and forty feet long it's right
on the sidewalk there's about a six foot
swath of grass there and as a matter of
fact Truman used to work in the office
literally in the front of the house six
feet from the sidewalk you know with non
bulletproof glass and as I've said
before there are a lot of hand grenades
in America then a lot of servicemen
brought him back and anyone with any
initiative could have come across one
and it would have been very easy to have
killed the president that way and the
only the the security at the Blair House
that day was a screen door with the but
you'll be you'll be happy to know that
the little hook was was in the little
circle
yes ma'am shouldn't that I met one of
your fans out in the parking lot that
drove 13 hours from there she's over
there I'm gonna sign every damn book
he's got so no I hope he's not
disappointed I felt a c---span it's
nothing I just didn't want to disappoint
this guy yes sir oh I'd say that's a
good I've actually thought about that of
using that but unfortunately that would
involve me going to Iraq and I think
I'll stay in watching the DC thank you
very much now the next book Bob Lee is
gonna go to Japan and there's some
fellows in Japan called Yakuza who are
gangsters and they carry swords so we're
gonna have some fun good old-fashioned
Steve hunter kind of fun yes sir we're
in my imagination or we're in America
well yes and no I originally Bob was
based on a Marine sniper named I'm
drawing a blank the great marine you
know you know it Carlos Hathcock and one
of the problems I had with that book was
I just read Charles Henderson's very
good book called Marine sniper which I
enjoyed very much and I was inspired I
was just I wanted to write about an old
sniper I just thought I thought of him
and he knew so much but he turned that
on that knowledge at great cost and that
I thought made him really interesting
and I guess a very hard book to write
because they had so many buried cuckoo
clocks and couldn't find the right voice
for the characters his first book I ever
wrote on a computer and I've done these
little bitty discs and I kept losing the
discs one point I this is I'm sure no
other authors made
is confession but I I spilled jelly on
one of the beds so I had to take it to
this guy to fix the disk and I said you
know what do you want what can I give
you and he said oh don't worry about it
so like nineteen years later he called
me up and he said Steve I'm in legal
problems and I need to charge you for
the disks I saved from the jelly so I
said how much and he said something like
six thousand dollars I'm not gonna pay
them we dickered had got it down a
little bit so one more question I'm told
it's and that frees his people on no one
wants to yes man you win well I was
actually a writer before I was a movie
critic I I published two books and one
of the reasons I wrote the books was
because I wanted to validate myself on
the newspaper and attract attention to
myself have them think of me as a writer
I was a very bad copy reader I was the
worst copy reader you know the the
Baltimore Sun of the early 70s looks
like it was put out by I don't know you
know deal literate and it was but I
wrote the two books and it made within a
newspaper it it made me quote famous or
a player if you will and so when the job
came open I was able to make a case for
getting it I got the job but by then the
books had begun to do all right and I
gotten used to spending that money on
myself and so I just kept writing the
books and it's just burgeoned into this
life where I do both these things and
curse every moment I'm not doing it but
but enjoy it and have been very lucky
and and I've had a very happy life thank
you all very much
this vintage photograph of Lee and Blair
houses in Washington DC diagrams the
November 1st 1950 assassination attempt
on President Truman co-authors Stephen
hunter and John Bainbridge met book TV
on Pennsylvania Avenue near Blair House
to describe the 38 second gun battle
that is the subject of the book American
gunfight
November 1st 1950 unlike today a hot
sunny day 1 end at either end of the
property there are guard houses in each
guard house there is a secret service
actually a White House policeman this is
the West this is the east priscilly o
approaches down this way what was in
that the small claims court install
approaches this way both of them down
Pennsylvania have
and they meet they don't meet but they
reached the ends of the property
approximately simultaneously and the
action begins this is where one of the
guard houses was at the east end of the
property there was a Secret Service
agent and a White House policeman in
this booth at about 220 oscar collazo is
walking down the street he passes the
two of them continues to walk in this
way he walks by the entrance of Blair
House up in that bedroom Harry Truman is
taking a nap they come to about here
he's standing here a White House
policeman named Donald Byrd Zell is
standing there he reaches in his pocket
he pulls out a p38 pistol and he pulls
the trigger it doesn't go off he bangs
on it eventually it goes off
he hits Donald Byrd Zell in the knee
Dalembert Zell is startled he pulls his
gun and starts moving out this way and
he moves out in the street meanwhile the
two officers about 25 feet down there
pull their guns and they start shooting
at O scar so Oscar is here o scholars
here being shot at by three different
men in fact a fourth man comes out these
heavy trees weren't here at the time so
we have four people shooting at us car
who's shooting back at them that's one
half of the gunfight this have been as
it
was this planned out by the two shooters
it was planned out they planned to be
here
they planned to do the shooting they
plan to assassinate the president the
United States and to make a big big
scene of demonstration for Puerto Rico
so it was not spontaneous but it seemed
like a lot of their planning for this
particular event had it was nothing more
than coming here and then blasting their
way in
so it wasn't didn't lack the subtlety of
a sophisticated military operation but
nevertheless ultimately wanted to do was
after they killed the guards or downed
the guards they head out there and get
into blue house that door which is very
secure now on that day was secured by a
spring floor that had been hooked so had
they made it all I had to do was push
their way through
they understood certain tactical
principles surprise and firepower they
had no meaningful advanced intelligent
they didn't know where Truman was they
didn't know how close they were to
Truman they intended to get in the house
sort of under rough opening blast of
fire and then look for truth nothing
remembers this this iron gate was open
this is the gates along here it were
around they were in place but this was
open so the access was just a walk up
here go up into the stairway Husker
cazzo sat down here on the steps trying
to reload his gun the officers from that
side were shooting at him and the
bullets were hitting
fence and they were breaking up that was
one reason why I survived and in fact
after the fight they found that several
of these steers which have since been
replaced had been shot off by Secret
Service bullets so while this fight is
taking on here there's another there's
another fight down at the other and a
much more dangerous so much deadlier
fight
Brazilians came this way he came going
in eastern direction down Pennsylvania
right here was a guard booth and this
guard booth was less Caulfield
there was also that's the door into into
the building and at that moment a police
officer named Joe Davidson was walking
towards us bounced back sorry Joe downs
was walking towards the door with the
bag of groceries that he was going to
take in priscilly aisle pulls a Luger
and at close range
shoots less Coffelt four times she only
hit some three times it's inside the
booth inside the booth and les never
even gets up he then comes over here and
he sees Joe downs and he shoots three
more times and he hits he hits hits
downs and knocks him down he pivots
sideways he sees Don burns el Donald
Birds L is the first white house police
officer shot he's shot in the knee
standing in right in front of the steps
he draws his gun and he crab walks with
his bloody blown-away kneecap out to
about here in the middle of Pennsylvania
Avenue at which point he starts shooting
at a scar who's standing right there
where all these fine people are walking
and at this point Basilio who is a long
way away he's at the edge of the
property over there he fires one shot
it's probably about 60 feet and he hits
he hits Donald in the other knee so
Donald who's got one through the Pacific
without a scratch he's been shot twice
in each knee shot once in each knee in
about 20 seconds and this is where he
goes to the pavement and passes out he
passes out right in Pennsylvania avenues
for a little farther out towards that
side cuz their trolley tracks here he
makes his way out of a pretty fair
distance across Pennsylvania Avenue but
at the time Brasilia hits him which is
again a remarkable shot for this guy
with a pistol in the middle of a gun of
a gunfight one of the interesting things
here is that trolley stops and who gets
out of the
Ben Bradlee of the Washington Post this
is his first he happened to be going to
work he worked the late shift
he lived in Georgetown he gets out of
the it gets off the trolley he here's
the last shot fired and he hits the
ground then eventually he gets up and he
gets his first page one story out of the
deal
okay then grisolia was reloading he
moves over here and this is what we
think is the moment of maximum danger
Harry Truman is in that window up there
you see it's about 30 feet away and he
comes to the window no we're not saying
he came to the window during the gunfire
what we are saying is that he was here
when he was either appear during the
gunfight or immediately after the
gunfight vasilia was standing here
he was reloading no one had seen him
that is to say the men at van into the
house were obsessed with what was going
on down there that's what happens in a
gunfight you focus on your immediate
what's happening what is immediately
threatening to you
the free man in this area were all down
the only one who was aware of where
Sileo was standing was in an office over
there looking out the window he was
later a witness at the trial so when
you're looking up at that window where
harry truman's poked his head out you're
looking through a tree here but that
tree was either not there or was much
shorter than from the pictures we've
seen at the time so it was a clear shot
it wasn't through the branches that the
CRA's Ilia was looking or could have
looked at this point late in the fight
it's been shot three times less
Caulfield somehow pulls himself from his
booze he gets out here he draws his
pistol and the range is about 20 feet he
fires one shot and he's the one who
finishes the shot because that shot hits
gros Sileo above the ear Basilio
twitches fall sideways over the booth
over the hedge the hedge was a little
different and then Vasily Ellis curls up
down there and that's where Basilio's
body is discovered meanwhile les who's
been hit as I've said three times sits
back down in his booth and slips off
into self-consciousness very shortly a
Good Samaritan will arrive from across
the street to help him and we'll get him
out of the booth and move him over and
he lies down here as he waits for the
ambulance to arrive there several
dramatic photographs of him lying on the
sidewalk here with his tunic his white
shirt covered with blood and this is
where they pick him up and take him to
emergency hospital he never regains
consciousness and essentially this is
where he dies this plaque was put here
for to honor Leslie Coffelt was put here
by Harry Truman back in 1952 and what
happened one time some time after it was
dedicated Harry Truman came back here
and was walking he was no longer
president and he came back walking with
I think a reporter from the st. Louis
post-dispatch and somebody else and he
came by and saw that the plaque wasn't
here and he became very angry very upset
and made some inquiries apparently had
been put off to the side somewhere moved
and he demanded that to be put back in
front back out front but he wasn't he
was no longer the president but this
man's death touched him very deeply
and it was always a painful something
painful to him for the rest of his life
he wanted to make sure this man was
honored and ever since then the plaque
is back out front and one of the people
rushing out to the scene afterwards was
a Secret Service man named Rex Cowton
who hadn't been right here but he'd been
close by I think he might have been over
the executive office building he comes
charging over right there at the bottom
of these steps austere Cleo's was lying
flat his feet on the left his head on
the right and right to the to the right
of this canopy stands Floyd boring
Secret Service agent who believes with
his detective special he that he has got
this guy who's now dead
Rex cotton runs up to him and says Floyd
her toad as his nickname was toad toad
what happened and and Floyd boring was a
very cool calm and collected former
Pennsylvania State Troopers looks down
says I think I blinked him in the beanie
and yes he did
but Oscar isn't dead they take him off
to the hospital as I said he survives
Oscar survives and then goes to trial
and is convicted and sentenced to death
then about a week before he is scheduled
to die in 1952 Truman commutes his
sentence eventually he is pardoned or
given clemency by Jimmy Carter and he
goes back to back to Puerto Rico where
he dies peacefully in his bed in 1994
this was a busy street is there any do
you have any record of eyewitnesses or
cars there were a lot of people quoted
in the papers and in fact the car did
stop and a guy got out and worked with
Bert shell there were literally hundreds
of people here I mean this was a busy
thoroughfare Washington you know closes
early had nice weather so there were
hundreds of people out for walks or
walking home and it's that that to me is
one of the most remarkable things about
this this outbreak of frontier violence
in downtown sophisticated cosmopolitan
Washington the most sophisticated you
know Street this side of Paris France we
spoke at length to the Good Samaritan
that Steve mentioned earlier who came to
at Lescaut felts rescue he was a 19 year
old kid was working on a sign try his
electricians apprentice heard the
gunshots and took it took a run over
but we got a sense of what this area was
like from him was again and he's still
around and doesn't it far from here
there's no yellow crime-scene tape there
are no you know barricades wooden
barricades
well you had essentially it was a kind
of a surrealistic crowd scene with
photographers other policemen emergency
medical personnel and detectives and
hundreds of citizens just walking back
and forth you know smashing the green
Reed who knows what was lost or
destroyed in that in that 20 minutes or
so many people consider just the
beginning of the modern security state
it was the end of the public's access to
the President and Harry Truman used to
walk from here where he was living over
to there the White House you could this
was a this wasn't sealed corridor then
it was Pennsylvania Avenue with trolleys
and cars and hundreds and hundreds of
people he used to walk back and forth
four times a day that ended November 1st
what happened from that day on he was
picked up and back of the Blair House by
an armored limousine and carried over
there and and that's if that's the point
that the president is removed from the
public thirteen years later we wish he'd
been more removed from the from the
public but that's a different story
Stephen hunter is a film critic for the
Washington Post he won a Pulitzer Prize
for criticism in 2003 John Bainbridge
jr. is a lawyer and former Maryland
Assistant Attorney General American gun
fight is published by Simon & Schuster